what
yes
oh
all right
you can't start without
hi everyone welcome to a more
full briefing room double the fun is
what i've been saying this morning
good you laughed thank you okay i have a
couple of items for all of you at the
top i will say have a hard out at one
o'clock but i'm gonna try to get to as
many
people in here as humanly possible uh
today the department of health and human
services announced that they have
awarded
200 million dollars from the american
rescue plan to support services for
survivors of domestic violence
as we all know the pandemic and its
economic impact
significantly increased the risks of
abuse for victims of domestic violence
and made it much harder for them to seek
safety and support
this money will provide critical support
through the family violence prevention
and services act
program it will provide 296
supplemental grant awards that will be
used to fund domestic
violence services in every state and
territory
as well as supplementary funding for
tribes state domestic violence
coalitions
national resource centers specialized
services for abused parents
and children grantees and national
domestic violence hotlines
also on covid to start off today i
wanted to well it's a second i guess
today
i wanted to give you a brief update on
our whole of government
wartime covet 19 response
we have gone from six percent of us
adults with one shot on the day
the president took office to more than
60 percent in just
four months we're averaging about 24
000 cases per day down from nearly 184
000 cases per day when we took office
and daily death rates have dropped
nearly 85 percent
since january 20th is there more work to
be done absolutely we're still at war
with the virus
a couple things that we've been able to
implement thanks to the american rescue
plan we've been able to accelerate and
improve our kovid 19
response school districts across the
country have been able to leverage the
resources needed to safely reopen
small and medium-sized businesses are
able to pay their employees for the time
needed to take off work to get the shot
and recover from it
and billions of dollars have gone to
states and loca and local organizations
doing the boots on the ground outreach
around vaccine confidence which is of
course
a big focus for us at this point hhs is
leading regular engagement with the
with the coveted community corps leaders
to discuss best practices
and just a few minutes ago we announced
the president hosted a youtube
town hall uh with a range of influence
influencers with millions of followers
primarily young people
who need to understand the benefits of
getting vaccinated so just another
example of the ways we're trying to use
all of our resources
here last things i would just note on
this
we've also worked with a range of
companies to
and a range of companies have stepped up
to ensure getting the vaccine is
accessible to everyone big businesses
from
from target to tractor supply have
stepped up to ensure their employees
have access
for paid time off companies are also
leveraging
creative ways to boost vaccination rates
united airlines is offering awards like
free first class flights
and other sweepstakes to vaccinated
travelers and starting today uber and
lyft will be offering free rides to all
americans to vaccination sites
until july 4th the last thing i just
wanted to note is that today the
president will be joined by
senator markowski senator sullivan and
congressman young as he signs
h.r 1318 the alaska tourism restoration
act this law will allow large cruise
ships to visit
alaska this year a critical step toward
returning to normal in a state
where one in ten jobs is in the tourism
industry
this bill is an example of the critical
bipartisan work that can be done in
congress
and the president is grateful to senator
murkowski and congressman young
for their leadership in this area and
for anyone who is here the first day we
took
a question from somebody remotely this
was exactly the question that he asked
um so
here we are just a few weeks later uh
with that darlene why don't you kick us
off
thank you um you didn't say when that
gold signing is taking place event today
yes this afternoon and then on
infrastructure
um can you say what the white house is
expecting next
from republicans after the white house
dropped the price tag last week and
following that very sharp statement from
senator capito's office
what are you expecting from republicans
on that front well
uh the ball is in the republicans court
uh we put forward
a proposal on friday that i detailed
extensively here and you all saw the
details of that proposal
uh in the uh written summary that we
provided transparently
to all of you uh and our reasonable
counter proposal
cut 550 billion dollars from the
president's original proposal
including to some areas that were core
priorities continue to be
core priorities to the president
investing in infrastructure
the last counteroffer that came from the
republicans
came up just came up 50 billion so our
concessions went
10 times as far as theirs so the ball is
in their court
we are awaiting their counter proposal
we would welcome that we're eager to
engage and
even have them down uh here to the white
house uh once we see that kind of
proposal
are you expecting the two sides to have
more discussions this week either here
or up on the hill
well i'll say we have remained closely
in touch at a staff level and senior
staff level here
uh with members and with their uh teams
over the course of the last several days
that will continue and again we look
forward to seeing their proposal
go ahead thank you uh just i want a big
picture as the country gets ready to
mark the anniversary of george floyd's
death if you will um
after that that happened the president
called this a wake-up call to the nation
um given where things are here in
washington with
police reform has anything actually
changed since mr floyd
was killed as it relates to policing and
black and brown people in this country
well let me first say that the president
is still very much hopeful
that he will be able to sign the george
floyd justice and policing act
into law and uh we are of course very
closely engaged
uh with a range with the negotiators
while also leaving them room to work and
just on friday
the president spoke with senator booker
we've also seen
that senator scott has publicly said
that the key for us is to keep making
progress
and we're going to con keep supporting
those efforts
um you know i would say it's hard for me
to assess from here
community community where we have seen
progress made certainly
uh the death of george floyd the tragic
death of george floyd has unfortunately
uh elevated into the public eye thanks
to the reporting from many of you
the need to put reforms into place the
need to rebuild trust in communities and
we're certainly hopeful that that
activism
uh that engagement will help move this
legislation across the finish line
and then a look back over the weekend
and over the last year this past weekend
there were more than a dozen mass
shootings across this country
uh 4 000 more people shot
and killed by guns in 2020 compared to
the year before
is there a crime problem in this country
well i would say certainly there is a
guns problem uh and that's something the
president would say and there are
communities where
uh local violence and community violence
is an issue and that's one of the
reasons that we have proposed
and have now are implementing funding
for community violence prevention
programs across the country
i will say that we don't often highlight
and you just gave me the opportunity to
the fact that between mass shootings
mass shootings that get a lot of
attention that we lower the flags
there are hundreds thousands of people
who lose their lives
and that's one of the reasons the
president will continue to advocate for
the senate passing uh back universal
background checks but also advocate for
actions in states where we have seen
uh the greatest level of activism over
the past several years does
it have anything to do with the increase
in numbers that we've seen in the last
year
uh in terms of local community violence
it's an interesting question i'd have to
ask our team to check on that i know as
i started off this briefing
giving an update on that we've seen
statistics on domestic violence
and obviously we know that there are uh
the loss of life at the hands of gun
violence
is often too often suicide uh can be
domestic violence and
we've seen statistics as it relates to
the impact on mental health but
i'd have to check with experts on the
assessment of that go ahead thanks jen
um are us based
airlines safe to fly over belarus right
now
are u.s airlines safe to spy over
there's not been an update i don't
believe
by our airline industry by our
those who monitor the airline industry
in the government in terms of
giving new assessments or new
recommendations on that and i'd
certainly defer to them
kind of following up on that in terms of
actions is the us
working with nato what's the president's
approach right now in response to what
occurred on the weekend sure
well first let me say the president was
briefed you know he's been kept abreast
of course but he was freaked this
morning during his pdb by his national
security
team our national security adviser jake
sullivan
uh also raised our strong concerns on
this issue
uh the actions of the government of
belarus with the secretary
with his counterparts russian
counterpart during their phone call this
morning which
we provided a readout of and it was
largely of course focused on
uh moving the ball forward on uh on
getting to a meeting but he also
raised this issue we certainly since you
gave me the opportunity to do this
condemn the lukashenko's regime's
ongoing harassment and arbitrary
detention of journalists simply for
doing their job
this was a shocking act diverting a
flight between two eu member states for
the apparent
purpose of arresting a journalist it
constitutes a brazen affront to
international peace and security by the
regime
we demand an immediate international
transparent and credit
credible investigation of this incident
uh we are
in touch uh with a range of partners
bilaterally and
through multilateral channels from nato
the osce
uneu and others and we have nothing to
read out at this point but we will
continue to coordinate closely with them
just one more quick one since we're in
kind of a critical week on
infrastructure does the president have a
trigger is he identified like
all right this is if i see this we're
walking or if i see this we're going to
keep this going past memorial day is
that
do you have that laid out kind of black
and white inside the white house right
now
i would say uh we're eager to see their
proposal and see what they have to offer
and i think it doesn't take anything
more than simple math to know that if we
came down by 550 billion
and they came up by 50 billion they have
ways more to go
go go ahead president putin and
president luchenko are very
close friends and allies does uh
the events with the ryanair and the
arrest of the journalist
is that going to have an impact on the
meeting and are are you prepared to
announce
a summit between the president and
president putin uh today
or when do you expect to be able to do
that well
i will say that as we provided in the
call readout
our national security advisor did have a
call with his counterpart um
and it was an important step in that
call was
an important step in the preparation for
a planned u.s russia summit the date and
location of which
we're not ready to announce at this
point yet and we're still working on the
details
uh i will say that well our focus and
the purpose of a meeting like this
uh will be to move to a more stable and
predictable
relationship with russia after several
years where it has not been
exactly that and we believe we can do
that in a constructive manner
it does not mean that we will hold back
on areas where we have concern
as you've seen over the past several
weeks where we have simultaneously
issued an invitation to have a meeting
while also putting forward sanctions for
actions that we find
unacceptable and so certainly um the
fact that the nationals our national
security adviser raised this issue is
evidence of that while also having a
conversation about
how we can move forward our planning on
the summit on another subject can you
give us a sense of what the meeting with
the george
lloyd family will look like tomorrow how
many members and family will participate
you expect that to open
uh for coverage uh what should we expect
i certainly can uh so tomorrow the
president is hosting
members of the floyd family here at the
white house to mark the anniversary of
his tragic killing uh this is going to
be a private meeting
and we certainly will also put out a
statement from the president
marking the anniversary a day that
certainly impacted him
personally and impacted millions of
americans but
um he wanted this meeting to be private
uh in order to
um have a real conversation and preserve
that um
with the family um he has a genuine
relationship with them
uh and the courage and grace of this
family and especially his daughter
gianna has really stuck with the
president as you have seen him talk
about
kelly and others many times over the
past several months so
he's eager to listen to their
perspectives and hear what they have to
say
during this meeting in terms of the
people who are attending uh
it is um let's see gianna
his daughter of course will attend uh
roxy washington his mother
bridget floyd his sister uh fellainis
floyd his brother
um his uh his brother's wife uh keita
floyd rodney floyd
his other another brother terence floyd
another brother
and brandon williams who is george
floyd's nephew
so it will be a full family attending
this meeting with the president tomorrow
obviously there's a deadline associated
the president asked congress that will
not be met
there's also been deadlines related to
infrastructure with memorial day wanting
to see real progress
is the president concerned that setting
deadlines on some of these key
priorities
has not been enough of a capitalist to
get action
is that a sign of how he's approaching
this
uh not working or a sign of something
else i mean these are key deadlines that
you've set
and some of them are not being met well
first i would say on the american jobs
plan
our timeline is really our own timeline
and that is that we will
be able to assess we will assess
internally
as we go into memorial day weekend where
things stand what the next steps are and
where we go from here
that can take a range of formats as it
relates to the george floyd act
the president used the opportunity of
his joint session address to elevate
a piece of legislation that is working
its way through
with bipartisan negotiations because he
felt it was important to elevate it and
important to
put out a bold and ambitious agenda now
it's clear
by the negotiators and by the fact that
tomorrow is the anniversary
that's not the timeline that the passing
of the bill will be on but he is
encouraged that there is
ongoing progress uh and that uh there is
a
um a sense from the negotiators that
there is a path forward and he
believes he can continue to press on
that go ahead
thank you on the origins of covid
there's a new wall street journal story
that three researchers at the wuhan
institute of virology were hospitalized
with symptoms consistent with both cobia
19
and common seasonal illness in november
of 2019 that's something that is
apparently
known to us intel officials so why isn't
president biden
pushing for more access more information
to get to the bottom of exactly what
happened
we are and we have repeatedly called for
the who to
to support an expert driven evaluation
of the pandemic's origins
that is free from interference or
politization now
there were phase one results that came
through uh we were not
uh during that first phase of the
investigation there was not access to
data there was not information provided
and now we're hopeful that uh who can
move into a more transparent independent
phase 2 investigation but with 589
920 dead americans at what point does
president biden say
we don't want to wait for the w.h.o we
don't know what they're doing this needs
to be an american-led
effort to get to the bottom of what
happened well first of all we need
access to the underlying data and
information in order to have that
investigation and why not
but he talks all the time about how he's
known president xi
for a long time so why can't you just
and we need them
i think you're misunderstanding how this
process actually works
an international investigation led by
the world health organization is
something that we've actually been
pressing for
for several months in coordination with
a range of partners around the world
we need that data we need that
information from the chinese government
what we can't do
and what i would caution anyone doing is
leaping ahead of an actual international
process
we don't have enough data and
information to drum to a conclusion at
this point in time
so is there any amount of the
casualties from colbit in this country
that would make you want to
not wait for an international effort and
just do it
as well i i have to say i think the
family members of the
loved ones whose lives have been lost
and uh deserve
accurate information data not the
jumping to a conclusion without having
the information necessary to conclude
what the origins are
what we do share everyone in this
country is a desire to know
how this started where it started and
prevent it from ever happening again
that's something we all share go ahead
thanks i want to ask you
first about the negotiations that are
going to be getting back underway vienna
tomorrow over the iran nuclear agreement
how would the white house assess the
status of those talks
it doesn't seem like there's too much
momentum toward an agreement
would you agree that things are kind of
grinding to
something of a halt here well we're not
going to predict
an outcome before the fifth round i
think if i'm remembering the numbers
specifically have even begun
look the fact that there are uh starting
a fifth round of negotiations
even as they are direct indirect is a
sign that
we're continuing to plug along on the
path to diplomacy we continue to believe
that's absolutely the right approach and
the right steps as it relates to
preventing iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon we know because we have been
through
this journey before that this is going
to take some time
uh that there will be moments where it
is challenging and hard and there are
difficult conversations
and that is certainly playing out but
the alternative
would be not pursuing diplomatic
negotiations and
accepting that we won't have visibility
or access to an
understanding of iran's capabilities
like we have
which is would be similar to the
situation we've had over the last couple
of years so we're going to keep
we have the best diplomats on the ground
we're going to keep plugging away
working with our
european partners and seeing what we can
achieve here there's one more
infrastructure
in addition to the obstacles with
republicans there is some
resistance among democrats to for
example raising the corporate tax rate
to 28
some democrats are really agitating to
repeal those assault
exemptions on taxes so can you lay out
some steps the white house is going to
take this week perhaps to get back in
touch with those democratic
lawmakers to address their concerns
because it seems now a deal might be
made among democrats and not necessarily
with republicans
well first i would say that we've had
500 about 500 engagements if not more at
this point
with our members their staffs their
teams
over the past several months on a range
of issues including the american jobs
plan
uh including democrats so i know we talk
a lot in here about negotiations with
capito but
i don't want that to uh confuse the
notion that we are talking with
democrats with leader
schumer with speaker pelosi with
committee uh chairs
all the time about what their priorities
are what they'd like to see in a final
package
and uh that's vitally important to these
negotiations moving forward
i will say that the president has been
clear he is quite open to a range of
mechanisms for paying for these
proposals including
a lower raising the the corporate tax
rate to a
lesser lesser percentage it's all about
how you pay for it right so it's a
numbers and
matter of numbers we've just put up ford
a proposal that
lowers the cost of the overarching
package by 550 billion
that requires less money not a math
addition but that is true
um so there's opportunity there what we
have not seen
from the republicans is any proposal on
how to pay for it that doesn't raise
taxes on
americans making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year and as it
relates to
uh the salt deduction we've heard from
members we're
open to having those conversations that
is not a revenue raiser as we know
that costs more money so that would
require
uh more ways to pay for it just any
specific engagements with those
democrats to read out that might be
happening this week
uh i'm i'm happy to see if there's more
that we can provide from our team i will
say that we're in constant touch with a
range of democrats from the problem
solvers caucus to which i know
are quite focused on the salt deduction
or a number of their members are
to leadership to uh ranking members but
we can see if we can get a summary for
all of you sure go ahead jeff
uh jack just a couple follow-up
questions first on
russia is it the white house's belief or
assessment
that russia was involved in the belarus
decision on that plane
i wasn't trying to jump to that
conclusion only to convey that as kelly
noted
there has been a close relationship and
so as we're discussing
ways we can engage to convey our point
of view
on the actions by the government of
belarus that we're going to do that
through many channels
our ambassador in belarus has also
conveyed that directly
to follow up on the china wuhan question
can you just give us a sense of
the white house's view of that report
that the wall street journal cited
is it accurate and is are you do you
have any concerns
that it may have been politicized i
would say
uh in terms of the report which was
specifically about individuals being
hospitalized
we have no means of confirming that or
denying that i mean it's not a report
from the united states
what i was conveying in response to
peter's question is that
it doesn't mean we can draw a conclusion
we don't have enough information to draw
a conclusion about the origins
there is a need to look into a range of
of options
we need data we need an independent
investigation and that's exactly what
we've been calling for
i think the journal cited a u.s
intelligence report so
that would have been a us report well i
don't have any i don't have anything
more on a us intelligence report from
here
okay and just lastly then on the issue
of infrastructure you've cited the fact
that you've
brought you've cut the proposal by 550
but a lot of that is going into other
bills so
is it really a cut if you're planning on
putting that money
elsewhere in other legislation some of
it is
uh not all of it is and we've certainly
come down from our proposals and
there's also bipartisan support for a
number of those proposals to move them
forward
so at the end of the day though we have
put forward a proposal we've put forth a
way to pay for it we have come down from
our original proposal
a great deal and we look forward to
republicans uh putting forward uh their
own counter proposal
uh so we can continue to negotiate go
ahead rija thanks jen
um so on the covid report are you saying
that the administration did not learn
about these three researchers seeking
hospital
care until the wall street journal
reported it
i don't have anything more on that for
you
on the belarus plane does the president
consider
the forced diversion a hijacking or not
uh i don't have a new definition of what
happened here other than
to convey that it was obviously were
outraged
as the international community has
expressed and we have expressed as well
and we think uh this was a brazen
affront international peace and security
by the regime um at this point uh we're
not legally ready to change any of the
existing language regarding the terms
hijacking and sanctions obviously there
are
processes to consider that thank you and
does the president plan
to speak with president lukashenko about
this or has he already uh he has not
spoken with him to date
i don't have any calls to preview our
ambassador has uh spoken with him
directly i've spoken with the leader the
government directly i should say
and just one more question on friday
president biden said he would not
allow the justice department to seize
the records of reporters
has he communicated that to attorney
general garland
and if so how did he communicate that
well i don't have any private
conversations to read out for you
between the president and his attorney
general what i can
convey is that uh the president uh
spoke clearly that he won't allow the
abuse of power to intimidate
journalists and he is alarmed by the
reports of numerous abuses of power
regarding the previous
how the previous administration used the
powers of the department of justice
and thought it was right to speak out i
don't have further specifics uh beyond
that
without revealing any private
conversations is the justice department
aware that they are not to seize the
records of reporters
well again i think the president was
always believes
that we should always be refining and
improving our approaches the president
made those comments
quite publicly so everyone i think is
aware
sure go ahead mike okay excuse me thank
you jen two quick foreign policy
questions
um one on israel yep um obviously the
the
the ceasefire seems to be you know
holding for now but there's
challenges ahead obviously for the
president who is under pressure i think
we're new pressure even today
from the left uh to do more for
palestinians and to
uh to do more to protect and and
enhance the quality of life for them on
the other hand you've got his pledge to
be
to essentially rebuild gaza which is you
know which is a
difficult proposition at best when hamas
is in
gaza so how does he see walking that
line
going forward you know and maybe in the
context of sending
um lincoln to the region as well sure
well as we announced this morning the
president asked
secretary blinken to travel to the
region uh to meet with israeli and
palestinian leaders
also with leaders additional leaders in
the region
to accomplish a couple things or to
discuss a couple of things
one is uh creating sustainable
conditions for a ceasefire
yes it is holding we're continuing to
watch it but there's a recognition we
need to continue to
uh discuss uh and have conversations
with
our key partners in the region who
played an instrumental role in getting
to the point we reached last thursday
and also to discuss the path forward on
rebuilding gaza and as you noted
mike we know that won't be easy in part
because
we want to prevent funding from going to
hamas we obviously don't
communicate directly with hamas given
they're a terrorist organization
a number of countries in the region do
and so the secretary's trip over the
next couple of days
will be focused on those objectives and
i'm certainly have the opportunity to
uh provide a readout to the president
when he returns uh
thanks and then on on russia
there was a part of the statement this
morning which mentioned
um strategic stability and the interests
of that the united states has in
working with russia towards strategic
stability which usually seems
or usually refers to nuclear cooperation
and and
and the limiting of
potential problems that could emerge
from the spread of nuclear
technology so is that is that um should
we see that as a signal of something
that the president particularly wants to
talk to president putin about
and you know is that also a signal that
maybe you're
pretty optimistic that this summit is
actually going to happen in a matter of
weeks because you're
already at that stage where you're
talking about uh that kind of that level
of
agenda well i think we we specifically
put in the readout that
the the discussion was an important step
in the preparation for a planned u.s
russia summit because we feel we are
continuing to make progress toward that
even if we're not at the point where
it's final and prepared to announce uh
in terms of uh
cooperation on uh nuclear uh
capabilities and threats
uh i will note that this is one of the
areas even with the heightened level of
tension
with russia over the past several years
where when the president came into
office one of the first items
on our agenda was extending uh the start
treaty for five years
um and obviously now we have five years
from now for that
but also they are an important partner
as it relates to the iran nuclear
negotiations that were asked about
earlier uh because
uh they are a member of the p5 plus one
so uh well we're not
quite at the point um of conveying what
the breakdown would be of a potential
summit that's not yet confirmed
i would um say that that uh discussion
continued cooperation on
nuclear stability would i suspect be a
part of the the agenda
uh go ahead thanks jen uh standing on
foreign policy a couple questions on
venezuela
sure um would the administration be
willing to ease sanctions on nicolas
maduro as a
gesture of its willingness to engage uh
and to facilitate talks with one voter
uh i've not been given any indication
that's in the works but obviously we
continue to consider
a range of steps uh with you know our
global relationships around the world
including venezuela
do you have does the administration have
any reason to believe
that maduro was serious about
negotiating his own exit
i really don't have an assessment of
that i'm happy to talk to our
team that oversees that handles
venezuela and see if there's anything
more we can convey
is the president personally involved in
this
policy portfolio what is his involvement
and does he see a window of opportunity
and negotiations
well the president is briefed regularly
on a range of our global engagements and
obviously we have a talented
team that manages relationships in the
western hemisphere both here and at the
state department
i don't have an assessment from the
president at this point in time he he
takes recommendations and considers them
from his national security team
go ahead thank you what's the
president's view
on the january 6th commission standoff
um
does he share thinking of some who say
comparing the day to 9 11
and that should be treated as such for
that kind of seriousness
and if he does
would he would he would he take some
steps himself like address the nation or
really get involved himself if the
republicans don't go along with it and
there is no
bipartisan position well we're not quite
there yet there are ongoing discussions
and negotiations the president believes
the attack on the capital on january 6
was an unprecedented assault
on our democracy he's repeatedly
conveyed that to the american public and
spoken
and said that in public addresses
he doesn't feel this is a political
issue this is really a question of how
we secure our democracy
and the rule of law we saw 35
republicans support
join democrats in supporting a
commission moving forward we're talking
about action
in the senate and uh certainly we are
going to continue to encourage uh
republican members to do the right thing
but ultimately it's up to them
what would he get involved if they if
they dropped the ball
no we're not there yet we're here every
day so we'll have a discussion if that's
the point we're at
go ahead um um if the infrastructure
bill doesn't get any bipartisan support
is the white house concerned at all
about it impacting other areas you're
seeking compromise police reform
being one of those areas and i asked
because mitch mcconnell said a couple
weeks ago
100 of our focus is on stopping the new
administration so it
doesn't seem like um they're going to be
coming to the table in any real way on a
lot of these issues
well first i would say on police reform
there are ongoing negotiations that both
senator booker senator scott
and congresswoman bass have all conveyed
are making progress
and they're encouraged by uh the tone
and tenor of those conversations
uh that's a good sign i talked earlier
about how the president is going to be
signing a bipartisan piece of
legislation into law later this
afternoon senator murkowski and senator
young will be here
uh there are a range of opportunities to
work together in a bipartisan way
including on the
frontiers act that has since been
renamed but you know the one i'm talking
about so
look i would say that our view is that
investing in our nation's infrastructure
preparing our workforce to be more
competitive
in the global community to compete with
china is something where there should be
bipartisan support we've put forward a
good faith
uh proposal it's now the ball is in
their court
but as it relates to your question about
um
senator mcconnell and what impact his
agenda will have
you know our view is that it's really a
test for
republican senators do they want to find
common ground do they want to engage
with the president about moving an
agenda forward for the
american people or are they going to
take all of their direction
from leadership and we see there's
opportunity to move forward
in a bipartisan manner even with those
comments made by senator mcconnell
and just quickly back to gun control
where are the talks on gun control
and more importantly has the president
talk to senator toomey or any of those
other
republicans that have talked about
background checks legislation for
example
well the president has had a range of
conversations with members over the past
several months and obviously
putting in place common sense gun safety
measures is something that has been a
priority for him throughout his career
he helped
pass the brady bill he helped get
background checks in place he helped
get the assault weapons ban passed and
he will continue to encourage
and push that with members while he is
president top of his agenda
in terms of the status of the
legislation i would point you to
leadership in the hou in the senate to
have a discussion about that
uh go ahead most of california is
already in a drought emergency
there's fears that wildfire season will
be
earlier and longer and worse than ever
this year
uh you're obviously we're about to head
to fema for a hurricane outlook briefing
you've been out some money but
what is the administration doing right
now
that could have an impact in this
current drought and looking ahead to
this year's wildfires
well it's a it's a great question and
i'd love to get you a more detailed
answer than i'm going to have in front
of me in this moment i will say that
there have been internal briefings
through the interagency through cabinet
level
interagency meetings and discussions
about how to address not just hurricane
season
but also the approaching season wildfire
season uh in terms of
exact funding and money i would have to
check with them let me just note if i
may
that um in advance of the president's
visit to fema
we are announcing as you may have seen
uh one billion we will direct one
billion dollars for
community states and tribal governments
into pre-disaster mitigation resources
to prepare for extreme weather events
and other disasters and we certainly
know that part of this effort is
preparing communities for hurricanes but
also for
uh pending uh fire uh the
forest fires that we know have impacted
many parts of california
we know where they may impact and our
effort now internally is to get ahead of
that
and work uh use every lever we have in
government in coordination with local
and state authorities to make sure we're
as prepared as we possibly can be
but we will we will see if there's more
specifics we can get you as well
go ahead yes on the alaska tourism
restoration act
one of the things that environmental
groups like friends of the earth have
said
is that the chronovirus induced paws
and big ship cruising has given the
government an opportunity to kind of
reconsider the environmental
impact of cruises and modify the
regulations is that something that the
administration is considering i would
say the department of transportation
would oversee any
new regulations or recommendations for
that as it relates to the cruise
industry so
the legislation as you know is um a
positive in our view because it helps
reinvigorate an industry that accounts
for a great number of jobs in alaska and
jobs that have been
on hold uh for the past uh year plus
well maybe more broadly then
is the human impact of the environment
something
that has been revealed by this pandemic
something that the administration takes
into account when it's
focusing on the better part of building
back better
human impact in general of the cruise
industry
in general across the board i think
we've seen evidence that the environment
has
flourished at times because of decrease
in industry is that something that when
you're thinking about
building back better is worth taking
into account sure
i mean i think if you look at the
american jobs plan and proposals the
president's put forward including his
ambitious
goal of reducing greenhouse gas
emissions by 2035
our view is that clean energy jobs
investing in clean energy jobs
which can help the environment uh help
ensure that we are protecting
uh our earth for our kids and our and
our grandchildren
can be done simultaneously while
creating jobs so i think
that initiative or that viewpoint is
central to
how the president sees his agenda and uh
certainly we've seen interesting data i
think that you're alluding to over the
past year as we've seen a slow down in
some industries but
um our objective is ensuring that we are
investing in um a sustainable way to
ensure that we can
uh create a system that's creating
millions of jobs while also uh you know
protecting our
uh environment over the long term on
cruises one of the reasons why
they've been able to restart cruises
from washington to alaska
is because these cruise lines uh are
testing people
for asking for the vaccination proof
from the guests
on these crews that's something that
states law and alaska
and washington allow them to do to abide
by these cdc guidelines
florida isn't doing that florida's
passed a law that prohibits
vaccine force does the administration
have a view on these kind of laws
and the impact that they might be having
on who's the
crews industry in florida i don't we
don't i will say that we are not uh
instituting uh vaccine passports from a
federal level we certainly understand
that
um industries uh will make their own
decisions about
how to continue uh their the work they
need to do
uh go ahead uh just a point of
clarification i guess on the
infrastructure so if memorial day comes
and goes
yeah the white house is not any more
satisfied than you are right now with
the republican offer is that the point
in which the president
asks senate leadership democratic
leadership to begin reconciliation
we're not quite there uh we talk uh
we're obviously in touch and working
with
senator capito and arrange a number of
uh senate leaders uh committee
committee ranking members who she
brought to the table we're looking
forward to hearing a counter proposal
from them
we also as any white house does continue
to talk with ambition to any white house
our white house does
continue to talk with a range of members
the senator
the president's looking forward to
seeing senator makowsky uh later this
afternoon
and congressman young and we'll continue
to look for ways to move forward in a
bipartisan manner
we're not quite there we'll do this
every day see where we go this week
one more point of clarification if i may
on uh the belarus the ryan airplane
it is part of this trying to get a sense
of sort of
how you classify what belarus
did to before you sort of figure out
what sort of approach what sort of
consequence may follow there certainly
is a process i
mentioned in response to we just
questioned about classifying right what
it looks like from our standpoint i'll
also say that an important part of our
effort is to coordinate closely with
our partners around the world and so
we've been in touch with them
uh over the last period of time and will
continue to be as we assess next steps
all right uh on the mitigation funds for
fema
for wildfires yeah 4.7 billion
uh on those monies do they come from any
does that take away from any of the
things that have been done with the
vaccination efforts using female money
uh i do not believe so
um let's see um i can
i can get back to you though on more
specifics about where the funding comes
from but there are
um you know obviously we like any
administration prepare for managing and
uh planning ahead for hurricane season
so it's a reflection of that
and one final thing on gun control sure
they've had a hard time
in the senate moving through with the
background
bills um with the legislative
calendar so packed do you expect
anything before the august recess
or is there if it goes into next year
with an election year
it's pretty dim so what kind of push is
the white house
planning to make on that well i will say
that
um the president believes that we need
to continue to press
for progress on gun safety measures and
the fact is the two pieces of
legislation that are moving
have moved through the house are for
universal background checks that's
something that's supported by more than
80 percent of the country
uh and so it shouldn't be a political
issue i know it is we recognize it is
but
the president will continue to press for
those uh legislation pieces of
legislation moving forward
he also believes that there's an
opportunity for activism and progress in
states
as we've seen on a number of initiatives
whether it's red flag laws and he took
some steps to
provide guidance through doj for states
to put in place red flag laws
uh or uh additional background check
legislation in states so
there's a number of levers that can be
pushed you know he
his position on on gun safety measures
is
is clear there has there's decades of
evidence for it and
he will continue to press congress to
move forward go ahead
uh yet another infrastructure
negotiations question for you
great you and and other members of the
amendment
administration have focused a lot on the
550 million dollars you took
off your offer but a lot of the senate
republicans over the past we consider a
bigger problem
is not necessarily the dollar figure but
more yet again the broad definition of
infrastructure and just massive
disagreement there
do you agree with that characterization
of where talks are right now
i think that's a little perplexing i
mean we're calling it the american jobs
plan
right it creates millions of jobs uh and
i'm not sure why uh it wouldn't be
infrastructure to
rebuild um and replace lead pipes
around the country which also has the
benefit of ensuring kids have
access to clean drinking water uh there
are a lot of areas of this bill
that um are maybe not in the traditional
sense but guess what
it's 2021 and we need to modernize what
we think about infrastructure what we
mean by it and at the end of the day
what we're just trying to do
is create millions of jobs and we're
hopeful the republicans will put forward
a proposal
come come meet us somewhere in the
middle a counter proposal
uh that uh can help accomplish the same
thing
aside have you seen any movement in
getting to the same page of how one
defines
infrastructure over the past few weeks i
would say we we kind of refute that as
the basis of discussion here at the end
of the day
uh we what we proposed is the american
jobs plan that
uh would invest in yes our nation's
infrastructure modernize it create
millions of jobs
make us more competitive put people back
to work
and that's what we're having a
discussion about and we welcome
a counteroffer from the republicans the
balls in their court
go in the back thanks john i have a
couple questions on tps
it was just granted to a hundred
thousand haitians and just announced for
burma
there's hundreds of thousands of
hondurans who were affected by
hurricanes and they're also waiting for
tps
and then also along that line on october
four
hundreds of thousands of central
americans are losing that protection
is the president aware of that deadline
and is he willing to
guarantee to all these hundreds of
thousands of people that have made their
lives here in the u.s that they will be
protected
if congress doesn't do what or passive
protection for them
well first let me note that over the
weekend the secretary of homeland
security uh mayorkas
announced a new 18-month uh designation
of haiti for temporary protection to
protect
status and as you noted uh there are
about a hundred thousand haitians who
could be eligible
for that uh in terms of assessing or
making recommendations on tps status
that would really be something that
would be done by the department of
homeland security and the state
department
certainly the president is aware and
certainly aware of the plight of many
people across the
across the world uh hondurans and others
who have
been impacted by hurricanes other
natural disasters and other reasons why
they certainly would be requesting the
status but i don't have anything to
predict for your preview for you about
additional countries being granted
status
the ones that are losing it on october
4th the
people that already have the tps it's
expiring october 4th
hundreds of thousands there were
families 30 people that were just
marching in front of them absolutely and
we're certainly aware of that and
october 4th is
several months away from now um but it
would be again a recommendation and
decision made by the department of
homeland security in the state
department
the last thing that i have is there was
a meeting here at the white house with
members of the hispanic caucus
and when they came out they said that
the president guaranteed that he would
be able to pass
immigration protections for farm workers
tps holders
and dreamers through reconciliation
if if nothing happens before that
when it when is there a deadline on that
is there a time where patients just
patience runs out as we were talking
about with infrastructure and jobs plan
and the white house just decides to go
along well i know that meeting was a
couple of
weeks ago i guess several weeks ago and
we've spoken to it since then
that that sounds like it was a bit of a
garble of what the president actually
conveyed because the president doesn't
feel that reconciliation
is uh the preferred uh path forward uh
for moving these uh these uh these areas
priority areas of immigration forward he
did talk about
in his joint address the fact that where
there is agreement
which there is great agreement on
dreamers and
even an agreement on uh farm workers on
moving this forward
we should move things forward in a
bipartisan manner uh and we'll continue
to press for that
last question is the vice president
planning on going to the border i know
she's
handling this why hasn't she been there
is she planning
in the future to go and see what's going
on firsthand
well the vice president is overseeing
exactly the same portfolio that the
president did when he was vice president
which is
uh north the northern triangle an
engagement with countries in the region
about how we can work together to reduce
the rate of migration
and and work together to address
corruption
address the root causes of why so many
people are traveling to our border
i expect she will make a trip to the
northern triangle at some point soon
so that would be where she would travel
given her purview go ahead
on infrastructure is the budget proposal
that's coming friday going to
incorporate the original infrastructure
plan into it or this revised smaller one
or can you tell us anything about how
you work
infrastructure into the budget on friday
certainly the american jobs plan will be
a part of the budget proposal uh that we
put forward on
friday um but well i'm not going to get
further ahead of what that will look
like you'll have to tune in on friday
come back
can you tell us if this washington post
story on friday that said this budget is
not going to include the public option
or a plan to reduce prescription drug
prices
is that correct well the budget will the
budget language and the budget documents
will certainly talk about the
president's priorities which include
lowering the cost of prescription drugs
and uh putting forward moving forward on
a public option
uh but this budget proposal is about a
proposal for the next
uh which will will encompass a number of
proposals he's already put to date but
certainly in the um in the
budget uh documents we put forward it
will highlight and emphasize
his priorities as president go in the
back
thank you jen um the salt deduction uh
mostly benefits wealthy people studies
have shown that
given the concerns about income
inequality in this country
concerns about deficit spending uh does
president biden support
doing away with assault production as
opposed to just lifting the cap
which some democrats wanted well
again i think peter as you know um it
requires money
um and the president did not put it in
his original proposal
because he felt there were other areas
that
warranted his support and would help
benefit a larger swath of the american
public but we also know that there are a
number of democrats
uh who and others republicans too of
course who support
different iterations of this i think
it's fair to say and
he's open to hearing from them and to
discussing with them
but as we're in the midst of
negotiations uh
it would require paying for for these
proposals and um
and that that is not a revenue raiser go
in the back
um thank you jan the white house hosted
president
moon of south korea last friday it was
one of the
first indoor large gathering uh invoice
involving
foreign visitors so um he already got
vaccinated fully vaccinated with two
doses of astrological vaccine
is there a list of vaccines that the
white house
accept as approval vaccination because
uh astrodomica is not approved by idea
yet
uh well i don't have anything to read
out for you in terms of specific
requirements of attendees that's not
something we're requiring here
as i think i read out on friday uh for
attendees for events we had an event
last week where we signed into law
at the covet hate crimes legislation
obviously
people who are attending events at the
white house would be tested that's part
of the requirement
but i don't think i have anything more
for you on that dc already
um had guidelines for people who are in
the united states were fully vaccinated
can travel pretty freely
what about international travel
travelers
will there be any like same rule applied
to
international travelers we continue to
review our health and medical experts
continue to review
the data and we would certainly refer to
them on
when they feel safe to ease those
restrictions and we certainly understand
the desire of
many people around the world to come
here and many people here to go travel
around the world
go ahead if i could just go back to
belarus what does the president view
as the most concerning action taken by
president lukashenko
is it arresting mr protocevich on
trumped up charges or is it diverting
the plane to land it and then to arrest
him
i mean i think they're both outrageous
and concerning
so if the u.s believed the charges
against proto-savage
were legitimate as it did with edward
snowden in 2013 when the bolivian
president's plane was forced to make an
emergency landing in vienna because we
thought snowden might be award
would the u.s still object to the method
used
again i think i've given an extensive
comment on this specifically we're
working with our partners around the
world i don't think i have anything more
for you go ahead in the back
i have a couple of questions once on the
southern border and another one in
colombia
sure this administration using title 42
to expel asylum seekers based on public
health concerns
the u.n high commissioner for refugees
has called this government to swiftly
end title 42
is that the intention and is there a
time frame that you're working on
specifically now that the country is
rapidly open
well we are still at war with the virus
yes there has been progress made but we
are still in the midst of a public
health crisis
so uh at this point we are still
implementing title 42 and uh we have not
changed our policy on that
i don't have any time for you if i may
go ahead um is president
abide in concern that the u.s might be
violating the universal declaration of
human rights by not accepting new
um asylum uh requests
in terms of from where
because of title 42
the u.s is not accepting um asylum
requests at the moment
well our objective is absolutely to uh
get our asylum reprocessing processing
system back up and running it was broken
it was
not working for several years and it's
going to take some time but we
that is our objective and something that
is a a priority for the president
colombia one last question thank you jen
dozens of people have
lost their lives in the ongoing um
protests and social
unrest that started in colombia a month
ago uh
ten days ago actually 55 members of
congress led by representative
jim mcgovern signed a letter to
secretary of lincoln
urging the us government to quote
clearly and unambiguously denounce
police brutality in colombia
is the white house that means you i
guess
ready to do so from this lectern well i
will say we welcome announcements by the
colombian government to investigate
allegations of excessive use of force by
police
the colombian government has as you know
has activated a special urgent search
unit to investigate reports of missing
persons with 35 search teams
deployed nationwide to follow reports
received through their 24-hour hotlines
we encourage the authorities to continue
to work
to locate all missing persons as quickly
as possible and we certainly encourage
those actions go ahead
um back to gaza um secretary lincoln has
made clear now is not the time to be
bringing up the t
state solution well the us has the ear
of both sides at the moment
um the world has watched 11 days of
fighting an awful death toll
when is the right time to bring up the
two-state solution well first i'll say
that the president the secretary of
state all believe that the only way to
bring a lasting end to the violence in
the region is for there to be a
two-state solution
uh between the parties it is going to
require these parties coming together
and
agreeing uh that this is a path they
want to pursue negotiations
they want to pursue and an outcome that
they're open to discussing
what the secretary is there primarily on
this trip is to focus on immediate
issues right now at hand which is
ensuring that we are creating conditions
with our partners in the region
for a sustained ceasefire and also
discussing the path forward on
rebuilding
gaza something that there's a great deal
of interest and support in the
international community on and there are
great needs on the ground
so that's the focus at this point in
time but we continue to
uh support of course a two-state
solution or any negotiations for a
two-state solution it's something we've
raised
uh already even prior to the conflict of
the last two weeks
uh with uh the israelis and other
partners on the ground
for me uh what more can you tell us
about the uh president's
um health regime we hear he's lifting
weights what sort of
weight is he lifting does he have a
personal trainer and what happened to
his peloton bike did he bring it to the
to the white house i didn't know where
this was going um
but i'm intrigued by it um i i will say
i have nothing to read out on the
president's uh
private exercise regime uh but i can
tell you having traveled with him a fair
amount
um sometimes he's hard to keep up with
schedule on his physical exam i know
you've asked about this before
um and it is something we will be doing
uh of course this year and providing a
transparent information to all of you on
i will see if there's anything more
uh specific i can get to all of you and
is he briefed on the specifics of the
covid vaccine and the incidence of
myocardial
myocarditis in some young people has
that been a part of his portfolio yes he
is aware of that and obviously as you
know
kelly um our health and medical experts
still continue to convey
that uh it is the right step for 12 to
15 year olds to get vaccinated that
these are limited um
cases and that obviously the risks of of
contracting kovid
are uh certainly significant even for
people of that age thanks everyone
we're waiting for a really tough news
day for the cat so
i've nella even on my secret